c'est la fin d'une autre journée de
suppléance pour nancy qui étudie à
l'uqam en adaptation scolaire et la boue
en être à sa troisième année d'un bac 2
4 ans elle travaille déjà beaucoup
tellement les besoins sont grands je
constate à chaque matin crime apple r
les deux commissions scolaires montréal
et laval pour la soutient
né à montréal de parents libanais elle a
toujours rêvé de devenir enseignante
tu vois les progrès d'un élève qui veut
ans qui va apprendre des super heureuse
de la fin on ne peut plus faire sa voile
croit kirpan équipe à 65 % des québécois
croient que les signes religieux devrait
être interdit en classe pour les
enseignants
presque un sur deux pense même qu un
enseignant devrait être congédié s'ils
ne respectent pas l'interdiction
j'ai vraiment années honnêtement qu'on
se rend dans une école tu peux trouver
des entraîneurs de toutes les
nationalités de toutes les religions
tout fonctionne il n'y a pas de problème
pas question d'enlever le voile
non non ça c'est pas c'est pas une
option
je suis québécoise musulmane je porte le
voir me dire de venir l'enlever c'est
comme si tu me disais enlevé quelque
chose de moi c'est inacceptable c'est
inacceptable l'alliance des professeurs
de montréal serait prête à défendre ses
membres jusque devant les tribunaux s'il
le faut essayer de convertir par exemple
les élèves dans l'école sorte est tout à
fait contre mais le port de signes
religieux pour nous ça reste un droit de
boucherville québec
la question divise les parents que nous
avons rencontré son influence pour leur
façon d'éduquer nos enfants pour leur
enseigner puis contraire ça que je suis
allé chez une personne extrêmement
ouverte serait à peu près tous très
souple très respectueux de tous que
j'élève mes enfants dansent à cette
optique
mais ce nom parce que pour ce que ça
représente je suis content
il faut embrasser la culture des autres
est la nôtre aussi
et je trouve que en éliminant sans nîmes
à noël ou quoi ça fait quand au petit
trot des cultures nous mêmes ce lors
signes religieux et consorts tourner ça
doit être le coureur s'il le faut oui je
déménagerai au canada
mais même des ménages et j'ai pas
vraiment envie parce que comme je dis
machine ici j'ai grandi ici
tout laissait sujet très sensible aussi
pour les directions d'école aucune des
commissions scolaires que nous avons
jointe n'a voulu commenter
pas plus que la fédération des
commissions scolaires du québec qui
souhaite attendre que le projet de loi
soit déposé avant de donner son opinion
ici jean sébastien cloutier radio canada
montréal